Abrams: One of the things
I really enjoyed
about developing
on Android
is all the debugging support
that the platform has,
and especially
the fact that
the simulator
and the device
are actually
quite similar.
You can issue similar
commands to each one.
There's a trace view
to see how your performance is,
and there's also
the ADB shell
to allow you to install
and uninstall, uh, your games,
and as well as see what
processes are running right now.
The sound support on android
is also really good.
There's support for many
different kinds of formats.
It's easy to load them up
and play them,
and it's quite responsive.
So some things
I'd like to see
to make Android development
a little bit easier
is the ability
to store byte arrays
into the shared preferences,
and also the ability
to simulate
saving and restoring behavior,
because the lifecycle
is very important
to Android development.